So we have to talk once again about Republican
Senate majority leader Mitch Mcconnell.
Mitch Mcconnell has, has really
emerged as one of the most insidious and pernicious
forces in American politics during the Trump
administration.
And he's doing really great things for Republicans.
I mean, if, if you are a Republican and you
are paying attention to what Mitch Mcconnell
is doing and has been doing for the last three
or so years, you probably think that the guy
is absolutely brilliant and one of the best
political operators in the game right now.
And that's true.
I mean, from the Republican point of view,
Mitch Mcconnell successfully orchestrated
the blocking of Merrick Garland's confirmation
to the Supreme Court under Barack Obama in
2016 he got Donald Trump, an additional supreme
court pick who will be on the court presumably
for decades and influence American culture
and society and, and uh, justice for a very,
very long time, insignificant ways.
Um, Mitch Mcconnell participated hugely in
the obstruction and a disinformation around
the release of the molar report and blocking
various versions of it and killing bills meant
to release the report.
It's a very long list of Mitch Mcconnell's
successes and now he is blocking bills that
are meant to fight election interference.
There is a bill HR one that the Senate could
take up, which would do a lot to protect the
elections and to fight interference.
And Mitch Mcconnell is not even giving it
a shot.
He says it's completely dead on arrival.
And the argument that Mcconnell and some other
Republicans are making is that the bill was
a poisoned to bill.
That it goes too far, that it contains the
wrong stuff and does the wrong things.
But what you have to understand is that this
is once again, Mitch Mcconnell's, well enough
calculated for the Republican base, uh, um,
uh, opposition because they've opposed dealing
with foreign election interference at every
opportunity.
It's not actually about this particular bill.
It's a much bigger issue.
They claim to believe the Mueller report,
right?
Even though they misstate what the Mueller
report says when they say the Mueller report
says no obstruction, no collusion.
They appear to believe and to trust in the
Mueller report.
Well, the mother report also says there was
significant foreign interference.
Russia was involved.
Wikileaks was involved with Russia.
This is a huge deal.
Russians access voting systems and I think
it was like two dozen states, 20 states or
something like that.
And Mitch Mcconnell has stood in the way of
actually dealing with that interference in
our elections at every single step.
You've got Robert Mueller and the intelligence
community and everybody who has any connection
to reality warning us.
Foreign interference is already happening
for the 2020 election.
It happened in 2016 and Mitch Mcconnell is
making it so that absolutely nothing is done
about it.
And of course, I mean if you want to follow
the money, Mitch Mcconnell is tied to Russian
oil money.
Uh, Mitch Mcconnell has voted to drop sanctions
on Putin, connected Russian oligarchs.
Mitch Mcconnell received more than $3 million
in campaign donations from a Russian oligarch
linked company, uh, all ALTEC Holdings.
It's all a swamp.
Mitch Mcconnell is right in there with it
and it would be great if Kentucky got its
act together and remove the sky because I
have to admit he's an extremely effective
republican operative, arguably one of the
most effective in recent history.
His involvement over the last, I don't know,
more than a decade specifically with the courts
and helping Republicans influence and control
not just the supreme court but federal judges
and the courts and justice system at a bunch
of different levels.
This is one of the most successful and mostly
out of the public eye political operations
in modern times and part of why it's been
so effective.
I mean, listen, controlling the courts helps
Republicans win.
Controlling the whole, the courts helps Republicans
get their away when it comes to social issues,
when it comes to corporate power and the,
the, the sort of deference to corporations
over the individual.
But part of why it's effective is not only
because of what it does, but because it's
under the radar, it gets way less media attention
too.
Over a 10 year period, slowly chip away and
take control of the courts in many different
ways.
Uh, that it also doesn't generate as much
loud and public activism against it.
Cause a lot of people don't know that it's
happening.
And even if Donald Trump leaves in 2020, uh,
is, is voted out in 2020 Mitch Mcconnell and
others, I mean, I don't want to give him McConnell
more credit than he deserves, but he deserves
some pretty significant amount of credit here.
They will have succeeded in this rightward
swing of the American justice system in a
way that is totally separate and distinct
from Donald Trump beyond Donald Trump.
Just getting that extra Supreme Court pick
thanks to Mitch Mcconnell Obstructing Merritt
Garland back in 2016.
So it's pernicious.
It's dangerous, but you've got to hand it
to Republicans.
They, uh, have been doing great things for
themselves, terrible things for the country,
terrible things for the world, terrible things
for just the average person in the United
States.
Middleclass person, lower middle class, poor
people, but for their agenda, this has been
extremely successful.
I think this is one of the biggest areas where
Democrats have just totally dropped the ball.
We talk about local organizing is a place
where the left, I don't want to say we're
not good at it, but we've not been good at
it.
We've not done it well when it comes to influencing
the justice system.
It's an other area where the left has to get
it together.
And you know what?
I know I've said this a couple of times this
week when we even had people on the left in
2016, maybe not a lot, but some of them were
allowed, uh, saying Hillary Trump, these are
both centrist clowns.
I don't like either of them.
And if it's not going to be whoever, right?
Uh, Bernie, Jill Stein, whoever it was, if
it's not going to be that person, I'm indifferent
between Hillary and Trump.
This is why the right continues to get favorable
decisions on corporate power and abortion
now and so much else because they understand
getting your person in there to pick supreme
court justices and to a point, federal nominate
federal judges, it has a massive impact.
They are beating us on this.
I don't want to keep losing on this so let's
actually understand it for what it is.
Extremely important and a very well crafted
strategy that Mitch Mcconnell has been a big
part of.
Let me know what you think.
I'm on Twitter at the pacman.
The show is
on Twitter at
David Pakman show,